[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 33 of
GameSpot after dark knee work from home
edition this is a bit strange
all of us have returned home for I don't
know the foreseeable future and we are
going to be doing this podcast out of
our houses and over discord well maybe
not this card we might change it up but
as right now we're doing it over discord
but joining me this week is Callie
plaguey Oh
jean-luc psyche Lucy James hello and
Greg Miller who you can kind of hear in
the background of Lucy setup right now
so sometimes you might hear him yell
something about the ps5 I have this
pretty meta there's layers on this
episode oh yeah I mean it's it's part
and parcel of everyone kind of getting
used to working from home I guess and
changing schedules and etc etc
everyone's gone through it yeah I
imagine there will be a lot of technical
hiccups throughout this episode so bear
with us I literally set up a camera
minutes before and it is not a camera
meant for webcaming but you know like in
a weird amount of high definition I know
you really it's a it's a Canon c100 that
I have and I tried to set up my like
digital camera but it just wasn't
working I was like well you have your
like setup the big guns fancy camera on
you're desperate now yes it it's taking
up like 75% of my desk you you also have
like her really nice depth of field
going on yeah thank you it's cuz I'm so
close to it - well I don't even put on
makeup for this that's how load F - I
don't even know if anyone else see that
I don't think any because we're not
recording the actual screen so no one's
actually gonna see our faces we're just
doing this a weekend well imagine it
better
imagine that we all look beautiful you
look great we always my weed beanie Oh
very quiet I'm really quiet yeah yeah I
just bumped you up to 200 percent on
mine oh geez
[Music]
yeah my mic is not even hold on I was
wondering when owners responding to me
it wasn't it collected let's all hello
I'm leaving I'm leaving all this in yeah
we're definitely gonna have some
adjusting period because I'm afraid I'm
looking at audacity and it looks like
I've been peeking a little bit so I'm
gonna try to yeah i've moved to my hello
hey no that's still pretty quiet I look
in a box
[Laughter]
he's you're just so far away since
you're working for your home hello near
me oh my god hey what happened I have no
idea I love that though yeah I think
we're gonna leave it in I think we're
just gonna keep rolling I'm not ready to
start over I was talking I was talking
about my weed beanie and how I can wear
it and not get in trouble because but
yeah so bear with us as we get used to
this setup we'll probably be doing it
for the next couple weeks at least
so I don't know you guys have any
suggestions tips if there's any issues
that you guys have noticed please let us
know apparently I need to fix my
microphone I don't know what happens
again Jesus okay we'll do the other
thing I do want to mention is that you
might see ads start to pop up and
gamespot after dark this is something
that another team has been working on
for a while
CBS is trying to kind of get all the
podcasts under the same hosting system
and part of that means ads automated ads
are going into a lot of these episodes
we're not entirely sure how it works or
when they're gonna start rolling out
however there's a good chance that I
think starting next month was what they
had mentioned before you might see ads
you might not they're gonna test them
out for a little bit so bear with us on
that I just want us to get to a stage
where we're like doing ads for Casper
mattresses man
I know blue Irene qui undies me undies
you get all those infamous like audible
restraints yeah audible what's the other
one um Squarespace oh yeah Squarespace
is a big one yeah but yeah get into some
add readings those are always fun I mean
could we do like if they do on my
brother my brother and me where they
just go real wacky with it that's what I
would want to do yeah I feel like that's
what we should do I don't think we'd
well I don't know we could be as funny
as them but they're very funny yeah I
mean a tional comedians but I think oh I
think we're funny I think John Luke
might be suffering yeah except employee
issues McLeroy brothers you know they
are they're not experts in advice-giving
but they are experts in being funny so
are you ok dude has Mike's gone we hear
you oh wow ok
hi look cool well if I don't spend all
day testing this setup and of course now
my work that's ok this is like the the
the like in terms of like high priority
productions I'd say this is a little bit
lower it's okay if we mess up a little
bit and and and things don't go as
planned but I think we're do I listen to
us is the tangents yeah I'd say so yeah
except for that one iTunes review that
was like there's too many tangents like
well I can't help you there how are you
problem anyway should we just get into
what we've been playing I figure we have
some I don't know a lot to talk about
considering a lot of us have been
shut-in
but yeah that is that is one exciting
thing right there are three new games
that we're gonna be talking about this
week I won't say what they are might as
well just let everyone introduce them
one by one wants to go first I volunteer
Lucy oh I was gonna say Callie okay cuz
I haven't really put as many hours into
this one as I would have liked but I've
been playing some
so no five royal which I've I'm only in
camera she does Palace so I'm still
super super early that you know like a
couple hours into the game so I'm kind
it's weird because I I started playing
it again last year because I was I could
bear I was really excited about it there
were all these trailers and I was like I
could really go for them persona right
now so I replayed the opening hour so I
have it more fresh in my mind I guess
and you can see the differences between
you know they how they're adding Kasumi
into the plot how they're changing up
the gameplay etc it's more fresh in my
mind so I mean immediately they've
changed that opening when you're in the
casino they changed the route in which
Joker takes to escape from the casino
because he has this new Batman grapple
gun type thing to fling you around
palaces now is that the same grapple gun
that he's gotten Smash Bros yes I think
so but you can kind of zip around and
they've reworked some of the palace
layouts to accommodate so it's not just
like your retreading old ground
you actually feel oh they have made
substantial changes and in terms of
gameplay I was talking to Michael about
it who is doing the review of persona 5
royal and he's God he must be what
60-yard I was in now it's a huge game as
of the as of his writing on Monday night
yes more now I'm sure it's a huge game
and so like this the big story changes
they made so persona 5 came out 2016 17
17 16 same years breath of the wilder
yes and I actually reviewed it gave it a
9 out of 10 I can see it on K spot um
and so for me it's actually quite nice
to revisit the game without the pressure
of having to review it on me so I don't
I don't envy Michael because it's such a
huge game and also there are tons of
other things coming out that and like
when I was doing it I had I think I got
the code a month before launch because
it been out in Japan for so long and
yeah it's a huge game the changes
they've made a quite subtle in the very
beginning it's still very much persona 5
holds your hand for about 10 hours
I would say when you're actually playing
it but they've you know put Kasumi in
some cutscenes you're introduced to her
in a very mysterious capacity in that
opening cutscene but the thing that
they've really worked on is gameplay
wise so SP is a really precious
commodity and persona it's like the
manor and it's how you can get your
personas to do cool attacks and it often
runs out which is annoying because I'm
the type of person who I tried to max
the social sim side of persona and try
and see as many confidence and build
those ranks and then I try and do a
palace in one or two days but sometimes
if you are really heavy on using your
personas you can't do that because
you're out of SP and if for example you
don't have enough money or enough SP
replenishment items it's really
difficult but the way that they've been
reworking the battle mechanics is that
if you level up sort of your baton pass
you can SP increase there are new items
you can find in palaces to do that a
whole new confident route with meroux
key is basically just improving SP and
giving Joker more SP so this is super
granular but if your persona fine you'll
like it all the blue cheat all the cool
changes that they're making to the game
new music ah
they put a new battle song in Michael so
it's better than last surprise I don't
know Michael was like this is fire
Michael said I don't really have many so
I don't know what Greg just heard so
what I want to do we have to do this is
like once this episode goes up we have
to try and time it with PS I love you
too see ya know it's like Michael said I
don't have many hot takes but the new
persona battle song is better than la
surprise was like okay I'll see I'll sit
like check with me in 30 hours and see
where we're at
I see one yeah have you met the student
counselor yet or does that come in till
later because that sounds kind of
interesting you mean him Shelia Leone
Satya and he's he's the competent route
that does yes P no that is Mookie yeah
let's merge okay okay so the twos the
two new common routes of murky and
because Kasumi
but also what's-his-face what this is
chops Goro akechi what's-his-face is
like a separate confident root now in
the main game you would level up with
him just through story now you have to
actively go seek him out and you know
you can hang out with him and you do
they does that change those scenes to
the those original scenes with them
still happen I don't know I all the
scenes because I'm still so early on the
scenes that I've seen him in I have been
from the main game it's like when he's
with SIA and like it need you mad at the
beginning I haven't got to that point
yet but Greg's getting excited about
save files I think in the background I
mean honestly it's for me it's nice to
just sort of dip back into persona and I
guess we've got a lot more free time now
it's it's weird not having a I know
everyone is also go persona once persona
5 on switch when but honestly not having
a commute anymore is quite nice because
I can just sit and chuck some hours into
it so I'm excited to take it at pace but
at the same time you know like the
Resident Evil demo I was out animal
Crossing's out I've got doom loaded and
I want to play that and I wouldn't I
wonder if I'll fall off it but I hope
the changes to the story are gonna be
big enough but I'm a little concerned
that they come so late because they have
a whole new semester so it's like you
play through persona 5 again with a
changed battle mechanics but then you
get the the new dungeon and all that
stuff anyway set of five great game some
what's a superb Oh superb guess what
that's a 900 tennis I didn't want to
shout out Michaels early review
impressions video than did I think it's
really charming it's a cute video he
talks a lot about the the stuff in in
the earlier stages of the game that's
different and then there's a lot with
Kasumi that you kinda have to wait for
that he's still waiting a check out
before he does the full review and cos
ask or anything like that yeah but I
really enjoyed that video
I was yeah I was in with him and Evan
when they were filming it and he was
just having such a good time yeah
chatting about it he's so cute
oh speaking of upcoming persona content
though we shot an episode of audio logs
for persona 5 royal with so Dimas on who
is the character designer and we went to
Japan who got to go to Atlas and he's
worked on pretty much every persona game
and it's kind of crazy and he talks
about Kasumi so look out for that
that's my pimping of content over to its
very good thank you jean-luc you are a
big persona fan as well do you plan on
playing royal or are you just gonna
leave it at p5 no I'm totally planning
can you hear me by the way okay yeah no
I was funny I was actually talking with
my brother about it about how originally
we're like yeah we want to play it but
you know don't know if I have enough
time and then we're both like well got a
lot of free time now so no I'm actually
really excited to jump back in I did a
like an impressions not impressions like
yeah yeah it was like an impressions
video with Michael back at a preview
been a month ago and just like cutting
that I was like man I love persona 5 so
much so I'm I'm really excited to dive
back into that one cool yeah I don't
know if I can do it again as much as I
love that spare that's a hundred and
whatever hours but I don't know I I it
sounds like you know well I'll have a
lot of free time so maybe I'll be like
you know what I feel like dipping back
into persona 5 still though to finish
that game again that'd be your big ask I
will probably do what I did last time
and like just sit there a giant bottle
of Diet Coke like a huge pack of just
like crap food and just try and play
because I mean I love that game but
there is a bit towards the end where it
is just relentless and I think that's
the way I used to describe it in my
review it's just like where are you I'm
not going to spoil the place that you
are but you just go it's like boss boss
boss boss boss and no rest by it's all
not I hope they've changed
I was before they shut down the office I
was talking to Evan and Michael and Evan
had mentioned he's one of our he's our
intern and he mentioned that he didn't
know that there was baton pass or that
you could get baton pass and I was like
how did you get through the final like
what fights because that is the only way
I got through them was by swapping out
my party because that was that one boss
fight in particular I don't know that's
based around like weakness swapping so
like you have to baton yeah to do it
correctly so props to him Jesus Christ
but tom is also a move in Pokemon oh
that's true
anyway that's persona 5 royal or royale
no royal Roy al is the thing with cheese
[Laughter]
alright well looking forward to future
updates on your persona 5 it's my
ongoing son Luke even playing a new game
that people are excited for as well
yeah I've been playing doom eternal uh
are you guys looking forward to do more
you are planning on yeah yeah I've got
it I'm gonna wait until this weekend to
delve in I think it's too much for a
school night yeah that's fair it's it's
a very intense game I mean pretty much
like ever it's like the best way I could
describe it is just like everything
about the first game just feels like
Ratchet it up I think it's a game that
feels incredibly like confident in what
it is like you can tell like the
developers like if you've ever watch
like Danny's like noclip talk on the
making of doom 2016 you can kind of yeah
it's small small youtube guy there's a
sense in that doc that like B they spent
a really long time trying to figure out
what that game was and a lot of it like
a lot of the things that people love
about it like it's satirical tone kind
of came together really last minute this
game feels way more confident like just
from the get-go it feels like
developers just knew exactly what they
wanted the game to be and what they how
they wanted to do it like everything
from just like the the shooting to like
the enemy design to like the balance of
combat just feels like so OnPoint it's
one of those things where like I love
doom 2016 and I don't think I could ever
go back and play it now because of just
like how good this is it sounded like
you fell off a cliff very slowly
could you see we all just leaned it a
little bit a little work and the problem
is I'm pretty sure that should upon them
according to you so I'm sure the this is
great well Jake let's be an interesting
at it I could we can still hear you we
could still hear you it wasn't like
before seems good I like it a whole lot
I think I was telling that to you guys
yesterday when we were like testing him
out but I really love the environmental
design is a lot better like the first
dude 2016 had like the three same
environments it was like Mars outdoors
Mars inside base and then hell and I
those eventually got kind of tiring like
this every level feels different you
have it it's like they kind of just go
nuts what they were like you have demons
evading earth but then you have like
okay we're gonna go to this like weird
alternate dimension planet of like
ancient fantasy like almost like
Crusaders who like fought demons and
like it really gets into that weird like
almost Lovecraftian kind of aesthetic
that reminds me a lot of like the
original quake like it feels like they
really dug down and just said like let's
see how weird and out there we can get
with the story I can tell my vo is
dropping
I'm watching at the levels oh my god I'm
just gonna keep going out of curiosity
have you finished the game yet I did I
did it took me about 12 hours okay
that's not as curious about because I
when I demoed it I played for around 4
hours or so and they're like yeah you're
not even like a quarter of the way
through the game and I was like I'm
worried about the light I was worried
about the length because I think I've
said it before I really like doom 2016
but I could not just sit there and play
that game I could only do like a level a
day I think part of that was because of
like what you were saying how the
environments are kind of repetitive
but yeah I was curious about doom
eternal in terms of like I guess my
stamina of playing it because before I
just like I could only do one at a time
as much as I enjoyed it yeah totally I
remember them saying I could see my
levels yep come on get back up up nope
nope Hey
okay yes what you need to do Jenner
because you need to control your voice
to make yes starts screaming when the
levels drop okay so yes I also was at a
preview event where they set a similar
thing to me Jake and I was also worried
that the length was gonna be too much
but it's totally not like it it feels
about the same life does that previous
one like it was it was 12 hours and by
the time it ended it felt like it was
anything at the right time cool I'm
definitely excited to check it out yeah
me too
and the review in progress is up already
right Kelly sure is um the so as of this
episode going up the multiplayer will be
live so we didn't have access to the
multiplayer pre-release will have access
to it when the game launches on Friday
ok today if you're listening to this and
so Phil horn shot will be checking out
the multiplayer over the weekend and you
should see the final interview but you
can read basically full impressions of
the single-player on games Bahrain
and if you can hear those sirens they
found me and they're gonna come take me
away can you hear them damn so loud I'm
so sorry I barely hear it it can't be as
bad as my come on let me check
no I want to check citizen I wanna see
what's poppin off Jake Jake Jake would
remember cuz I used to live right next
to a hospital and my windows had no
installation so anytime or installation
and anytime anyone would like be playing
a game with me
you would hear everything and it was
just dude we'd be playing stage and I
hear sirens and this was when I like
first started playing siege so I'd be
like wait is that is that the game what
should operator ability is that Charlie
do you plan on playing dooms multiplayer
at all yeah I'm really curious to check
it out especially cuz Michael and you
seemed like pretty positive on it from
that preview event we're gonna play it
for community Fridays which I guess if
you're watching this at the time this is
airing then we're gonna be doing that on
2 p.m. Pacific time on Friday but I'm
curious to check it out I don't know if
I'm gonna play it much more than like
the weekend I don't know if it has
enough legs for that but I'm at least
curious to try it out
yeah from from what I played it seemed
like a fun like side activity I don't
know if it's the kind of multiplayer
you'd sink hundreds of hours into cuz it
didn't seem like there was much
progression there at least in terms of
like upgrading your class or your or
your doom Slayer because right when you
start you have access to pretty much all
of your doom Slayer weapons and all of
the available demons and it was
interesting because it was like a tense
back and forth between the demons and
the doom Slayer but man you really have
to be on top of your [ __ ] you really
have to know how to play doom I feel
like if you're gonna do that because me
is someone who would only played a
couple hours and when we familiarized
myself with a handful of weapons jumping
into that multiplayer was incredibly
difficult and maybe also is because we
were playing with people who had been
testing it and already ours sure and
they know what they were doing but I
like I can't imagine
trying to balance that mode because it
it seems like it would be really
difficult but they when we talked to him
they were like yeah we think we've got
it in a place that at least at launch
should be balanced obviously things
could change mm-hmm but yeah I'm curious
to see if that has legs to it because it
was pretty neat and I don't know it they
said it sounded like they were gonna
continue to support it so it could be
interesting to see where that goes but
yeah I don't know if it's for me I think
I'm just gonna do the doom eternal
single-player and call it at that God I
was watching them I was watching Dave do
it do some like nightmare mode
single-player gameplay with no hood and
I was like Jesus Christ yes I mean I
don't think we shout out Dave enough for
how good he is at first-person shooters
yeah he's kid reflexes are unreal and
like watch it be on YouTube like by now
all the stuff that Dave is done it's
crazy like I was getting anxiety just
from watching it shout out to Dave yeah
one thing I also wanted to mention about
the game that's kind of weird is it
takes its story super seriously this
time like the the thing it's kind of
weird I go back and forth on it we're
like doom 2016 like a lot of things
people remember about it is that it was
like it wasn't taking itself too
seriously like you know the doom Slayer
just like breaks everything and and you
know doesn't listen to what everyone's
saying this one it's like there is
definitely some satirical stuff this is
really good like a hologram of the the
UAC that like has a lot of like that
kind of like jokey like tech jargon but
about hell but otherwise it's like this
very self-serious story that has like a
lot of lore and you got to look at the
codecs to understand what's happening I
kind of love it in that it's like it's
so self serious that it really does
remind me of those like old ninety
shooters but I think if you're somebody
who was used to just like how
tongue-in-cheek the first one was you're
kind of gonna be thrown off by it yeah
that's interesting I wonder if their
thinking was like oh doom 2016
like like we could have like another big
franchise here so we have to figure out
how we can build out this world without
yeah you know maybe that just led to
them making a more serious maybe yeah
game just interesting anyway moving on
cally what have you been up to this week
um over the past couple weeks I guess
for a while I've been playing animal
crossing new horizons my reviewing
progress is live yeah it's it's been
interesting because I've been playing
for time on day 20 now and there's so
much that I feel like I haven't seen and
I feel like I've been doing a ton like I
on day like 16 I hit 80 hours 16 or 17
so I haven't checked in a couple days
but um there's a lot of hours to still
have nukes cranny and you know like
there's building upgrades I haven't
gotten yet so I'm kind of concerned
about that I'm worried that the upgrade
is time gated from what I can tell from
from people I've talked to it it could
take a really long time because I'm
skipping on you I'm not I'm not I don't
like doing that in Animal Crossing it
makes me feel like the cops are gonna
come get me and but I talked to people
who have time skipped and it seems I
mean I don't know to be fair I think
time skipping is that's like cheating an
animal crossing I feel I feel like
you're really cheating yourself if
you're not yeah you're playing it day by
day because there's something really
special just about about like watching
your town grow every day and seeing how
things change and I and I feel like if
you're just skipping ahead like I
understand some people probably had to
do it in order to I don't know for their
reviews or for previews and guides and
whatnot but I would if you plan on
getting this game I wouldn't recommend
skipping ahead but you know you play it
however you like yeah I would not but
generally I am really enjoying it it's
something that I really like about it is
the way the new system
incorporate with the existing Animal
Crossing Corps like loop of daily tests
and chores so like crafting was when I
was really really nervous about I've
said that before but I think it works so
well because look I thought it would be
a ton of resource gathering and that you
wouldn't be able to to get the kind of
cool unique like go to the store see
what's there every day but you still
have that because there's some stuff you
can't craft there's like bespoke
furniture basically and then there's
like your the your set of things you can
craft and that expands that library
expands over time and then the actual
gathering of materials for crafting just
is part of my daily set of things that
I've done for years and animal crossing
games like you would hit rocks every day
right because one of the rocks has money
in it every day now I hit all the rocks
partially because I'm trying to find the
money one but also because there's
resources in those rocks so it's like
this is a chore that I am used to doing
that has become more lucrative so that
that task becomes more meaningful
because you get more out of it or like
shaking trees I would shake trees in
previous games because you can catch
wasps you can sell wasps for a lot of
money there's furniture and trees
there's bells and some trees now there's
also tree branches which you can use to
craft like tools it's a big one that you
would craft with that and tools are
breakable so it's important to have a
good supply of tree branches so that's
just it's it's just part of something I
would already be doing so it doesn't
feel like this huge extra thing I have
to occupy my time with that said it does
give you more to do if it's like like
some you know because I'm stuck at home
I'm like well I might as well chop wood
might as well chop every tree and get as
much stock up on wood cuz maybe tomorrow
I won't have time to get more wood like
doing stuff like that so I like that it
just feels natural it feels like a
natural extension of when Animal
Crossing Rd is about and I got the clown
villager the sheep that looks like a
clown I got him
oh really yeah me removed out and in the
clown yeah so I had a villager who was
like I'm gonna move out and I was kind
of like I want to see what happens she
wasn't like she was fine so I let her
move out and then I went to you can go
to like deserted Islands using Nick
miles there's a separate currency and
like I went and the first one I went to
you Pietro was there and I was like do
you want to live with me we love how
those conversations go down to and ever
you meet a villager on island you're
like you're just basically you should
live with me no that's a great idea they
like pack up all their things in there
there the next day and also his
catchphrase it's Hong Kong have you seen
role deer I haven't I've seen okay so so
it was so been djenka his roommate has a
collection of the cards so so once you
get but once you get the camping site
and Animal Crossing new horizons you can
basically scan amiibo cards and then
they'll come and visit if they're in the
game we think and Ben's roommate had the
rolled card so I was like I'm getting
rolled in here right now so I brought
rolled in talk to him a little bit he
had me make something for him so I made
something for him and I was like hey do
you want to move to my town and he was
like ask me next time like well we're
about to lock down the office so I there
won't be a next time so it's either Now
or Never
so I don't have rolled in my ten but I
did meet him and he is he's great yeah
I'm so excited I'm gonna download it and
because what it looks 9 p.m. Eastern
9:00 9:00 a.m. our time so yeah I would
start that night just cuz ya know
there's a lot of stuff that you won't
get until the next day so if you wait a
day you won't get like the museum prep
like that I mean it's not like I've got
a lot on ya post
I've changed my workouts turned by 5
p.m. I'm done every day I'm like what
the hell am I gonna do always time no
commute play play at once yeah and
that's kind of what I mean
oh I also do want to mention the knick
mile system because I think it's really
smart it's basically like a separate
currency that and you have like a you
have like a phone in a mobile phone in
the smartphone mouths word in game
called the Nook phone and it has a map
and the app tracks you're like Nick
miles you get like stamps for different
things but it's like stuff you would be
doing anyway so like fishing you get
stamps for like getting a certain amount
of fish so it's just like an extra
benefit to the things you're already
doing and you get to spend them on on
cool abilities like the tool wheel and
new hairstyles and I'm really worried
about shampoo dole know if hairy it's
gonna have a job cuz you can change your
hairstyle it anytime oh [ __ ]
I'm holding out hope that there's like a
set of like more extravagant and wild
hair styles and colors that only she can
do because right now I have all of the
hair styles and colors that you can get
through the Nook miles program but I
still feel like it's kind of lacking
like even you Cal you're mentioning that
there were some hairstyles that have
been an animal crossing games previous
but aren't in this one yeah like the you
know the cowlick hairstyle where it's
like the two pigtails and then the girl
she has like one pigtail on the top of
her head like that's I haven't seen that
and it's like maybe that's not like a
super cute hairstyle but that's like one
of the starting hairstyle mm-hmm that
yeah I do have some dope wigs and hats I
got the crown that's a million bills
you bought what's it I bought it dang I
am on the final house upgrade it is one
two million four hundred ninety eight
thousand bells and it is the last one
and if I finish my house payments before
nook's cranny upgrades I'm gonna lose my
mind yeah that's another interesting
thing that I don't think you've
mentioned or did you mention how nooks
crannies for either of us has not
upgraded yet and we're almost like what
we're almost 30 days in we've paid off a
majority of our debt it's kind of wild
yeah it's um it's interesting although I
can see
so like we know LaBelle is in the game I
haven't seen LaBelle yet but I've seen
some hints about LaBelle so I there I
know there's more coming
I also just want to brag we started in
February at the tail end of February so
we caught some fish you won't be able to
get until November damn so that was
really exciting so maybe do try and
travel if you want those fish and
potatoes fish or you could visit at her
Jess's island oh yeah yeah the southern
hemisphere or Jake you have a burner I
have a burner account that's in the
southern hemisphere so you can just
visit that one and tell everybody what
you named it burner t'en because I
couldn't fit burner town because it was
one character too many so I cut the W
and just called it burner Tim yeah my my
island is named Midori which is what my
new leaf town was named because I didn't
think of Johto soon enough
so my boyfriend's named his town but no
he hasn't named it by Island he joked
about Ba Island but he's named his
Florida too oh do you want to know what
I named my Island
you're not Penn Rivia Oh tips video and
I pray my sickle day I was like Jacob I
don't know what I'm gonna name mine oooh
when a villager asks you like the
villagers will still come up to you and
be like oh I came up with this nickname
for you it's so good and you could tell
them I don't like that and then give
them a new one you should give them
Geralt yes I call you Carol that's my
villagers are all calling me guacamole
[Laughter]
bait all of them all of them one of them
was like can I call you baka moly and I
didn't have the heart to tell him no and
now they all call me blocking wallet oh
man it got around town so fast
I want them all to call me big papa I'm
gonna do that I love it when you call me
big papa
exactly gret I just remembered Greg
named his his town his Island Smallville
which is very hard that's very it's like
it's like you're doing because some
people have like really good names that
mean a lot or like cool fictional places
and I'm like don't call it Penn don't
call it Penn don't call it Penn so sorry
I was like oh is that a lost thing the
last no no no no just met penis land it
would be funny but I think I'd probably
get banned from old Nintendo Online
Services someone will go to Isabel and
be like Lucy's Islands name oh my god I
don't want to go then you have Isabel on
your back you don't want that no another
thing too that I wanted to shout out
about Himmel crossing are the villagers
just in general like the things they do
and the the activities they take part in
are really adorable like you go and see
them stretching in the in the town
square do yoga like they'll do yoga or
like they'll fall asleep under a tree or
read a book under a tree or you can see
them walking through the museum and
you'll ask him about it and they're like
whoa did you catch this this is so cool
and it's just like I don't know it's
it's really neat seeing how how much
more I don't know I guess animated and
personable these animals are them before
cuz like you mention your view of Cala
David they've always been like funny and
clever but now I feel like they're funny
and clever and they have these like cute
personalities that shine through just in
their stuff they do every day like I
have one one character named Genji and
he's super into working out so every
morning I'll see him like with like some
dumbbells just doing curls and like a
workout outfit and you know be like you
know just getting my daily routine in
here and like I love this he's go Genji
it's called Genji and he calls me a
talker like over lunch he's like he's
one of the like Japanese they have
different outfits like all of the
villagers have rain outfits some of them
have little rain hat
they have pajamas they have workout
clothes they will like it it's because
she's gonna cry the detail is amazing I
almost started crying because I walked I
said this in my review I walked into the
town square and one of my villagers was
singing a song to himself and I was like
Jake can attest to this I was just like
they watched him for like a half an hour
sing this little song and then another
villager came up and sat down and
watched him - oh my god ever seen I've
been taking so many screenshots yeah I
also today I I went to ham fries house
ham free as one of the three hamsters
who lives in my town and he is his he's
like a cranky villager is his
personality and he goes same he goes
like hey kid have you used a computer
before what am I saying of course you
have but today was my first time my
friend showed me his computer and he
asked me about the hard drive and I was
like I walked I didn't drive that's the
localization team the localization is
incredible also there's two visitors who
will come flick and CJ who are new and
they'll do like they'll buy like bugs
and fish
flicka's bugs CJ's fish and they both
are incredible flick is like a goth bug
enthusiast and hello he one of my
favorite things he said about one of
those before Lucy I think of dad one he
like he says something like it would be
pure hubris to assume we know everything
there is to know about insects
woof I mean he has piercings all right
yeah
and then right DJ the the fish guy is a
streamer he has
he does live the streams of fishing and
he's like I got to do it for my fans and
like every time he comes to your town he
gives you a challenge like a fishing
challenge and today he's in my town and
he was like you got to do this like you
got to catch these big like big fish and
three in a row without messing up sorry
chat requests localization I'm so
excited to play one of my one of my
villagers the other day was practicing
safe distances and whatnot cuz he was
sick he was like don't come any closer
to me and I was like oh no this is - I
know I have a have a facemask that I got
in the game and and I bought extra I've
literally stockpiled medicine in the
game but I do that in every Animal
Crossing game because if one of your
villagers just sick and a store happens
to be closed for remodeling and you
can't help them you got to have written
medicine on hand
well now you can craft and you can craft
it mm-hm so anyway anything else you
want to add about Animal Crossing um
yeah I think you know the way I said my
review is still in progress my biggest
concern right now it's like the pace of
upgrades it definitely feels pretty slow
but I think there is a lot to occupy
your time in between that I'm really
having fun I basically just started like
decorating my island and laying paths
and changing the way rivers are like
terraforming it so I feel like I have so
much more to do and I'm excited because
Isabel gives you a a star rating and I
want to get that 5 star rating well I've
also been playing Animal Crossing new
horizons but a game that I played
through last week which I did want to
talk about a little bit is Black Mesa
which is the mod of half-life 1 the
community made remake of half-life 1 and
I was super impressed I have never
played half-life before never played
well I've dabbled into a couple of times
I couldn't get into it we on the Orange
Box I had the orange box I'm
we played portal on it and a little bit
of Team Fortress but I could not get in
half-life for some reason and I figured
it was just because I hadn't played one
so I decided to finally play one through
Black Mesa and I was super impressed I
loved it all the way up until the last
level and I know they've made changes I
think it's called interloper I think
they've made changes to it from the
original to make it better but man was
it still rough is the change they've was
it
I haven't beaten Black Mesa but I'm
actually playing it right now I know
that it so they've changed all of his n
which is lay a lien world at the end is
OK is just the ending bad or is like all
of his end not so so I actually really
enjoyed Xen itself like I I thought that
that section was funny-looking we're
just the it wasn't too overwhelming like
it was just that last chapter called
interloper which I felt like it lasted
for hours
sure and it was just running through an
alien box factory or something and there
was i I don't know like it was
frustratingly long I was having so much
trouble getting through it other than
that I thought it was fantastic though
did they still keep the weird baby final
boss yeah baby you know there yeah which
which was a fun final boss fight when I
first saw it I was like oh this is one
of those games that just completely
botched the final boss huh oh yeah I
thought and I was like well I mean it's
it's like I was expecting like levels of
bioshock's ones last boss but but I
thought it was much better than that it
was a fun fight to say the least but I
really enjoyed it and I'm bummed I never
played a half-life I before I I highly
recommend it it's like I think it's like
you don't need a play half-life one
outside of like the curiosity of it all
if you're somebody who like just wants
to know what that original versions like
like if you just want to I I would tell
people nowadays just like go play Black
Mesa
it's a half-life one but better in
almost every way I would say like yeah
even if they do botch that ending like
the ending a half-life one was also not
great like Zen kind of sucked in the
original so at least it's better in this
one
yeah I like I said I enjoyed then I
think the thing that confused me the
most which I later found out it was
because there's DLC or there's a there's
an expansion for half-life one that I'd
like because I started half-life 2 and
one of the characters was like it's me
Barney do you remember me from Black
Mesa and I was like Dawg I just played
Black Mesa and I don't know who the hell
you are and then I was talking to
Alessandra Barbosa and he's like oh yeah
that's because there's a there's a
there's an expansion that was he was in
the expansion for half-life 1 and I was
like well I'm not playing that so I
guess you read a paragraph on what that
was to fill me in that's the thing is
like half-life 1 story is like kind of
minimal like like Black Mesa actually
added more story from 2 into the
original like dr. kleiner and Eli Vance
who are major characters into and like
all the other games aren't even in
half-life 1 like they show up in Black
Mesa they like retro actively put them
in but like yeah I don't think you ever
really really need to play that original
game for first story outside of just
like a plot synopsis you could look up
yeah I might do that cuz I did start
half-life 2 and so far maybe it was
because the remake is newer but so far
I'm not super in half-life 2 yet maybe I
got to play more I think I'm only on
like chapter 5 or 6 so I still have a
ways to go where you at
I just finished was it highway 51
highway what's the one with all the bugs
on the beach and you're in the oh yeah
hi hi wait I forget the name of it
highway something yeah I just finished
that did you know I did like that level
did you not like Ravenholm that's kind
of the big regular everyone close okay I
really liked Raven home I I see why
everyone really liked that level and
like how it just kind of flips to horror
and you can definitely see like I don't
know I saw a lot of like left 4 dead
inspiration
I was sure from that specific section to
which I thought was pretty cool even
though Turtle Rock is you know the
original left 4 dead was not valve but
yeah I was curious because like it was
one of those things that like at the
time like blew your mind because you
just like weren't expecting the game to
like do a complete 180 and become like a
horror game for like you know an hour
but at this point like everyone knows
about that level so I was I was curious
if it still held up as someone who yeah
played it I don't know if it landed for
me as much as it did at the time just
because you know McCain looks kind of
dated now it still looks great to be
honest but it looks dated and I didn't
know that their raven home was where it
becomes kind of a horror game because
you know people have been talking about
it for so long and i had known about it
but I still really enjoyed that level
for the most part but I yeah I'm not
super into half life to quite yet at
least not as much as black at least not
as much as I was into Black Mesa so I'm
gonna keep playing because I want to try
to burn through all of them before I
don't have that Alex I'm gonna say if
you're not into it at this point I don't
know if you're gonna fully get into it
like if you're not into it by that bye
bye
Raven home it's like I mean the rest of
games so great in my opinion but like I
don't know I don't I don't think it's
kind of necessarily yeah I don't think
your minds gonna get changed
yeah well can't stop now no I'm curious
what you think of the episodes because
they they integrate Alex more into the
game like she's a she's like a companion
character who follows you the whole time
and like especially episode 1 introduces
some like really interesting like
puzzles and mechanics I utilize her as
like a companion character so like I
think it does a decent job of mixing
things up and there's like a car you get
into and it like they move outside of
the city so like the environments are a
lot different okay yeah like I like this
episodes quite a bit but em I'm super
curious what you think of them yeah I'm
definitely gonna keep playing it I I
think part of the reason why I like
Black Mesa more is that I really like
that area 51 style setting where it's
like oh you're going through this
factory there's all this weird
classified stuff that you're not
supposed to know about but because
there's a disaster you have to go
through here anyway and there's one
point where a scientist it's like you
know more than or Gordon you know more
than like any one man should ever know
and I was like
yeah this feels really cool and then
like the opening to half-life 1 I
thought or half-life 2 was fantastic
with city 17 but like yeah when I
started distance myself away from there
I was kind of losing interest but like I
said I'm gonna keep playing anyway shall
we move on we've been playing a lot of
games
well Animal Crossing in half-life about
it I didn't get to talk about well I
don't really need to talk about it I'll
say as I've been playing Last of Us
again and it was a bad idea
shouldn't shouldn't do that I accept but
plague inc i redownload it plague and
clickin [ __ ] so so like last of us like
the now that I've like gotten into like
the 20 years later and it's like
everyone's clickers it's like okay this
is obviously its own thing and I don't
really it like now it feels fine but
that opening 15 minutes like you find
like a news report talking about like
mysterious infection that's like people
hospitals overcrowded and quarantine
cities and I'm just sitting there going
like oh god this no thanks
that intros brilliant it's really good
it's still that game it's it's fun
replaying it because the well the act
the acting and the dialogue holds up
incredibly well and it's still like some
of the sharpest writing and acting I
think in games the gameplay just
sometimes doesn't hold up I've had a lot
of weird like bugs with like character
walk cycles like they just keep walking
back and forth or like the some guy not
seeing me in stealth or a guy seeing me
when he shouldn't it was like
mechanically I don't think it's held up
as well and I'm very very excited to
like play too because I want to see like
how they improved that because I feel
like very confident that like the story
and the writing is probably gonna be
good so I feel like mechanically I want
to know like how they've improved it cuz
I do think that is not aged great yeah I
mean what I would I had played of two at
the event God couple months ago more
than that was that it it's
retain that like you know how last of us
it was very difficult to kill people
early on like they made you're aiming
really mm-hmm really shaky and you had
to make sure to get headshots if you
want to take people down and enemies are
very persistent it still has that but it
doesn't feel as clunky or cumbersome
okay cool at least from what I played a
blast of us to I think part of it is
just playing as Ellie over Joel because
I think even Naughty Dog and Neil
druckmann shared a tweet today of how
much more agile Ellie is compared to
Joel and I remember that sticking with
me especially from what I played just
because I could climb up things jump on
things I felt much more limber and quick
which was exciting I'm so excited for
that game yeah oh really quickly I
should really quickly want to say I
watched bling ring last night out of
desperation [ __ ] what was Emma Watson's
accent in it bad she was gonna have yeah
she was going for valley girl and like I
don't think Emma Watson's in place
stupid like she can't act like I don't
think she can act period that too I it
was not on a good accent she couldn't do
valley girl and at one point she goes I
want a Rob oh and I was like that he was
honestly like we were just my mom was
just like let's Google some Netflix [ __ ]
to watch and that was on a list so we
watched it we were like that was
phenomenally boring and can't believe
you watch a movie we watched Dawn of the
Dead the other day which is a great
movie I didn't realize James Gunn wrote
it really oh really but yeah we watch
that you wouldn't oh quickly so let me
explain the mental connection I've just
made in my mind it's AK Snyder did dawn
of the dead everyone always says about
Justice League hashtag released the
Snyder cot did you see the [ __ ] that
went down about cats
yes about to bring that okay so a viral
tweet
okay brace yourself a viral treatment
round oh wait wait let me let me read it
out and find it hold you just going to
like the text with me okay so a VFX
producer a friend of a friend was hired
in November to finish some of the 400
effects shot in cats movie his entire
job was to remove CGI buttholes that had
been inserted a few months before which
means that somewhere out there there
exists a butthole version of cats
release the bot hole cut but also
someone some replies to that tweet with
but that also means the conversation was
had about both putting the buttholes in
and removing well this episode is going
to be called to release the bubble oh
wait some of these some of these replies
I worked for Disney many years ago and
we made the grave mistake of printing
thousands of marketing pieces where
Mickey had a butt crack
they made us destroy all of it because
Mickey doesn't have a but that's like
Pokemon has all these like wild rules
about like different things allowed to
and not allowed to save up Pokemon like
of course Mickey like canonically
doesn't have an ass anyway release the
butt hole cut sorry I just really had to
explain my a little jump in thought
processes PlayStation 5 yeah should we
talk about the PlayStation 5 details
that was a exciting stream I watched all
of it all I can tell you is that the
hard drive the or the solid-state drive
is gonna be really fast and you can't
buy other hard salt state drives that
fast for another year - can we talk
about the production value of that video
yeah I feel like that's the best thing
to talk about this I saw a lot of people
being like man that was
and I was like I love that they
attempted to like make it seem like it
was this like conference you had so for
the they had like fake ID where they you
know they were real they won't because
they moved cuz I spent a long time
looking to make sure that they moved but
I'm pretty sure it was like animation
like an animation like they recorded
like 10 minutes of them and then just
like overlaid it
what like schist yeah wait they just
play it on loop maybe dude I'm not I'm
not sure what you're talking about when
did that happen in speed where they're
on the boss and they faked the security
cam footage so they get everyone to sit
really still and then they loop the
footage to make the terrorists believe
that you know they're not veering off
course oh yeah because the woman picks
up her bag or something and the guys
watching he's like we've been absolutely
done in here yeah I think that's what
they did cuz I was looking at it and I'm
like I'm that has to be like just a loop
of people they did anyway I appreciate
that they went all in on that
I mean honestly like people I saw so
many tweets being like oh this is so
boring but I'm like this was that GDC
presentation this was always gonna be
about tech specs I don't understand what
you want from them but also I want to
give like I host a lot of things as a
job like we all host things Jesus Christ
mark Cerny
like not only is he he spoke the entire
was it almost an hour
he didn't stumble he except he was so
eloquent and he was explaining concepts
that I don't know how he did it he's
some kind of wizard but it was like he
was explaining concepts that were both
high level and for laypeople at the
exact same time and he didn't it was in
like incredible and also he was
basically just a one giant ASMR machine
mmm super into me yeah that was
impressive
it's not like I know I wasn't the target
audience for that talk but I was still
like damn it really takes a lot of
talent to condense complicated topics
not condensed but like get them down to
something that's understandable for
anybody
yeah he's so intelligent like I am gin
afraid of how intelligent he is I wonder
like god they think it's one of those
things where anytime like him or like
what's his name john carmack like talk
I'm always like what are you doing
making video games like why are you
working on this and not something like
super serious that could actually help
the world
I guess the video games are heavy games
good help I already know I want to know
what they do in that downtime I'm sorry
I'm really just still thinking about the
things he must know like God just the
way he was talking about it like it was
nothing and I'm sad that trying to keep
everything straight in my head I was
like Jesus well okay now I'm thinking
about what mark Cerny does in his
downtime yeah I want to eat plays next
yeah well yeah we interviewed him blood
I mean Kelly we did he was so lucky it
was really nice really nice yeah and I
felt bad that I was like felt so bad
that nak is a meme like I really got
emotional about it after because he was
really really sweet to us he was so
sweet and we went Oh what was the other
thing that was happening that we weren't
allowed to ask him about oh it was like
this is oh me oh I think it was just
like ps4 Lodge and I was like no please
please keep you PL was like please give
you a questions focused in back and were
like yeah we were like oh but he's the
architect of the PlayStation 4 there is
so much more you want to like we want to
talk to about but like he was so nice
and you can tell that that's his like
that's his passion project and it's but
what does he do in his downtime I think
he like reads books and drinks tea yeah
do you think he like has like a special
interest hobby like maybe he reads a lot
about like zoology or something oh yeah
there you go cuz like I I have a lot of
fun reading up on on like what animals
could be cryptids you know I don't know
anybody else has done this but sometimes
I'm like sea monsters what could they be
and then I read on Google for a while
maybe like that real-life murder maybe
oh if he's a Midori no I love that baby
damn we got to get him on the podcast he
was I don't maybe he was too sweet to be
a murderer you know that not that we're
like horrible awful people but he was so
sweet
yeah oh email Sony I'll ask what we
really want to interview mark Cerny
about his hobbies just what he does I
you know what I'm with Jake I think he's
like really into T to the point where
like like people who are really entities
only drink loose leaf tea right and like
he knows that like green tea is just a
minute the black tea you want to steep
for like four or five minutes and herbal
tea you want at least boot put in for
seven minutes and then like he has like
his whole he has different a use for day
person his tea routine I have a friend
who was really into tea and we would
make teen and we had cast-iron teapots
my old roommate so we would like we had
these cast-iron teapots when we get
these nice like tea snoopers and like I
said scoop a tea scoop that scoops you
the exact right amount for one cup of
tea I used to have a kettle that had
different buttons for specific types of
damn long Darjeeling Oh gray cuz
different teas need to be brewed to a
different temperature they do I think
marks Ernie's really in a tea yeah I
just revealed things about myself
projected on the work 30 jean-luc what
do you think mark soon he does in his
free time a bug collecting I think he I
think he collects bugs okay or or like
maybe he collects flowers it likes
presses flowers yeah
a little book yeah wait are you Ben I
think what we're all saying is that
monsoon he's an animal crossing villager
in real life like he just has all these
[ __ ] he has all these wholesome
hobbies you know when do you think we'll
hear more about PS 5 man that's a good
question part of me is like wondering if
it's gonna get pushed from well
Microsoft Microsoft doubled down like
there was the they accidentally one of
their sites said coming Thanksgiving and
then Microsoft went no still holiday
2020 I also feel like someone at
Microsoft was just like sat with their
finger over the button there which is I
mean to be fair that's what PlayStation
did to them with ps4 and Xbox one right
like they were just wait for one of them
to go first and the other one would be
waiting Oh was it the the like the
presentation that they did for the price
of the ps4 and it looked like it'd just
been knocked up like that day oh yeah so
I feel like they're just kind of in that
game right now but I feel like maybe
it'll wait until Last of Us is out the
way and then though yeah then they'll
probably do a big event online I could
see that it's interesting too because he
mark Cerny kind of mentioned that
backwards compatibility won't really I
mean it'll kind of be a thing with the
PS 5 like some PlayStation 4 games will
be playable on your PS 5 but it won't be
to the extent of the series X which will
play all your Xbox one games and some
360 games and some Xbox games yeah which
i think is interesting right I think
everyone kind of anticipated that this
next generation everything would be
backwards compatible and even people
were theorizing that you could be able
to play like ps1 games PlayStation 2
games play three games but it's clearly
at least not now
I think at least not yet it's not the
case it just speaks to how difficult it
actually is to do that because they were
saying that one of the reasons they were
saying is that the PS 5 was so fast
that it would games wouldn't ps4 games
wouldn't be able to run correctly
because of how fast it is so they have
to go in and manually tweak its it's the
same thing with like the the whole
reason Xbox 360s backwards compatibility
is just like they would dole them out
like you know a week at a time or
whatever is because they have to
manually go in and like tweak them on
their end till I get them to function
properly so I it's like cuz cuz like I
want to say like the ps3 had by ps2
backwards compatibility that was like a
straight backwards compatibility but
that was no way and some consoles they
they got rid of them yes and I had one
of those and there would be games that
had problems like I played I tried
playing persona 4 on my ps3 and um the
like lower bar where it tells you where
you are had no text so I never knew
which I never knew which dungeon floor I
was on like you'd have weird graphical
hiccups like that so I think like the
idea of just like a here's just a
straight all-in-one like backwards
compatibility solution is like not
really feasible in terms of like there's
gonna be issue so I think they're making
the right call by like doing it more
like case by case and they're gonna
really like make sure each game works
properly but I am a little disappointed
I was really hoping I don't think I
didn't think I was gonna happen but
there's a part of me that was like I
wish there was like ps3 backwards
compatibility because there's a lot of
like really good gems on that system
that you can't play unless you use like
PlayStation now which I don't really
care for yeah I'll be curious to see
what they do with PlayStation now too
cuz right now that kind of seems like
it's watch I don't know it's hard to say
what stadia is up to but it seems like
that is the streaming service that's
kind of lagging behind I could be wrong
though I have not used PlayStation now
much apart from playing a bit of red
dead redemption I think the wall and TPS
Plus subscription I would hope so I
think yeah well this is like that's my
with Microsoft's games with gold or
Microsoft's gold or whatever games
passing you like having that it's so
nice having the I don't know what I'm
saying no no you're right though like
their game pass ultimate comes with gold
and it's supposed to also come with ex
cloud which is their Darrin is now X
cloud that's the looking for
I think Lucy's right like if they want
to compete with Microsoft they would
also need to make this like really
appealing all-in-one like bundle package
that gives you everything anyway should
we move on to questions sure all right
before we get into it though if you've
got questions please feel free to email
us at after dark podcast at gamespot.com
we were a bit light on questions this
week which is understandable I feel like
a lot of people have a lot on their mind
but if you find the time to send us a
question or if I don't know we'll read
it no matter what there's a good chance
it'll be on the episode so yeah feel
free to send us a question but Kelly do
you want to take the first shirt hello
after dark crew with the end of the
outsider and the start of Westworld I
have a question throw your way HP has
hired you to create a new show based on
an adaptation what video game movie or
book would you adapt my choices would be
Mass Effect because I feel it would make
a better show the movie also I would
like to see a Bioshock show that takes
place before and during everything going
wrong at rapture Thank You Josh from
Ottawa I do say so first of all Thank
You Josh for writing in I do want to say
I don't want to talk about Bioshock
because I have gone this long without
getting support I mean this isn't a
spoiler for Bioshock but like speaking
of West world West world season 3
because I'm doing the recaps on geus
universe the plot of Westfeldt season 3
so far seems to be the plot of the
Minerva's Den DLC from a shock to and
all there is a computer that controls
human I was like I've also just played
Bioshock 2 and my name is den like last
weekend I was like what this is not a
coincidence like the Nolan's and
Jonathan Nolan Lisa joy they must be
game is like it's I know it's a sci-fi
trope but I feel like they must secretly
enjoyed by shock - I feel like West
world in general had a lot of references
to games and whatnot just from the
couple episodes I watched there's some
real capital G gamers over there
OHP absolutely
yeah although can we just take a brief
not moment of silence because that's so
awkward on podcasts but just to
acknowledge that the outsider just went
so downhill rip dude I haven't finished
it I stopped it finishing it I yeah
that's what I heard anyway like there's
one line in the last episode that
actually made me kind of emotional but I
think it's just because I didn't have
friends growing up and I just hit a very
specific part of me but other than that
I I mean
classic two shits the bed yeah yeah I
don't I don't know I I have such a hard
time I think I would love to see a
screen to the moon adaptation mmm um I
say that because I think a lot of games
work primarily as games like the games
stories that I like could only be games
that I like best so like undertale for
example I think it works specifically
because of the game mechanics and how
they interact with the narrative I think
gone home is impactful as a story
because of how that mechanics interact
with them in a turn narrative to the
moon I love I cried so much playing that
game but I don't think it needed the
game mechanics to be that impactful I
think it was just an impactful piece of
writing on its own and so that's why I
think it would make a really good film
adaptation
I think Red Dead Redemption HBO show in
the vein of dead I was gonna say that
directed by James Mangold or show run by
James Mangold yeah I feel like it would
miss a little bit of that like that
feeling of the futility because it's not
you doing it but would I watch it a
hundred percent yes yeah yeah
Red Dead for sure or Last of Us that'd
be a good one
[Music]
that one I that's another one I don't
know how that works without you in the
driver's seat I would I'm very
interested to see how they translate
that because I think so much of what
makes that's I mean because there's an
argument to be made that the Last of Us
is just the road the video game and that
you know I think there's there's a layer
that you get from the interactivity I'm
very interested to see how it translates
I think for me it's that it's just a
straight adaption like it's gonna be
really hard imagining those characters
and those scenes redone because I feel
like I'm just gonna be comparing it
because like I was saying I playing it
I'm still like engaged in those
cutscenes so much they feel so well
acted that I'm gonna be watching that
same scene on a TV show and I'm just
gonna be comparing it I'm gonna be like
oh well the Joel on TV didn't deliver it
as well as Troy Baker did and I feel
like that's gonna be a really big hurdle
to get over yeah well I mean to Callie's
point too I feel like part of the reason
why the Last of Us struck such a a chord
was because you were the one pulling the
trigger and I feel like the second you
they could still do it and I'm sure
it'll be I hope it's good but I feel
like it's gonna be a very different
story if you're not the one who's doing
these things because I think a lot of
the emotional payoff in that game is
when you reflect after you finish the
game you know like oh that was me who
did all those terrible things to protect
someone it's not watching characters do
it necessarily I mean it still is right
like there's still cutscenes where
you're not in control of but like like I
think of that last scene sorry last of a
spoilers here but when you go into the
when they're about to operate on Ellie
and you kick open the door and there's
the doctors there and you don't have to
shoot those doctors but everyone does
because they're feeling so worried and
defensive for at least they go in and
shoot those doctors but you don't have
to shoot him and they'll just back off
they'll just like drop their night their
scalpels and be like you take her we we
don't do anything but so many people
just run in there because they're so
invested and they pull the trigger and I
feel like moments like that
are what made that game so special and I
don't know how you're gonna replicate
that on the show but that's not to say
that you can't tackle different themes
within that world with with those
characters to make it resonate I still
can't believe Craig Mattson is doing
that and Borderlands oh yeah
he's right in the borderlands movie I
don't need ya I don't know how you do
that at all
like tales of the borderlands which was
sure make it a Saturday morning cartoon
that would be a great addition to the
Tales series of RPGs Tales of Symphonia
tales hmm
[Laughter]
I I just wanted to give us a shout out
for avoiding the phrasing of the
narrative dissonance for so long I
wasn't gonna say it I will say though I
like Josh is a suggestion of a Mass
Effect sure I would I would watch the
hell out man I think you can make the
same arguments about like of a part of
Mass Effect's thing is that you get to
make the decisions but the world I would
still watch it cuz that world is dope
like that you have like an entire lived
in you you know you have a universe to
occupy whereas you know when you're
talking about like a one-off story I
mean I think especially the shorter this
game the the less world-building there
is generally so it's like you know gone
home takes place in one buildings it's
like not give me my Garris Bukharian
CSEC cop procedural show yes the [ __ ]
out of that it's so good every week I
would watch the shot out of that yeah
yeah me too so good one of my favorite
moments in games is when you have to
recruit Archangel and you don't know
something you cross the bridge and it
takes off his helmet and it's Garris and
you're just like he's back and he's got
like one leg up on the couch and he's
like changing I'm like the first thing
you can say is like you look like [ __ ]
or something like yeah
man I should not play those games yeah
yeah I always thought Mass Effect
especially liked to just look again I
agree with you guys I don't think I'd
want maybe to directly adapt the games
but like I remember when I played to it
is almost formatted like a TV show like
episode ox yeah yeah like each mission
where you like recruit a person do their
loyalty mission like I'm just like that
is so like you could you could be like
oh the first half of the season is like
recruiting everyone and then the mission
where I forgot the plan at horizon where
the the with the collector where the
collectors kidnap everyone that's like
your midseason break and then you have
like the second half and then the big
season finale would be the collector
home worlds like I was thought as a high
schooler I just was like man that'd be
so [ __ ] cool write a script send it
to HBO yeah screw HBO from genre script
at HBO - I'm oh your consideration I
don't think I ever like wrote anything
but I guarantee you I like thought about
like how it would be structured like
this is what I would do and this is who
I'd like cast as a person for mass
effect otherwise I don't really know
maybe Yakuza would be kind of weird and
interesting I don't know though because
I something about it as a game about
like walking around and doing all those
like weird side quests is like what
makes it work for me I don't know if it
would work as a TV show but I think the
world of Yakuza is like such a
interesting blend of like serious you
know
macho badass jock is a plus like goofy
nonsense you could you could make
something I think out of that world in a
TV show I mean in a similar vein
Sleeping Dogs
oh yeah sleepy dogs had a really good
story at the heart of it it is it's just
a really good like Hong Kong yeah action
film God that game is good yes pretty
Channel and Assassin's Creed series
you know who could probably direct a
good Yakuza show or movie bong joon-ho
maybe because he is very good at
swinging between like serious funny
serious fun oh yeah no work no totally
yes no I think that's a great idea say
it again
sorry I was I was thinking about bong
Joon so it's just like a guy talking
about like how like George Washington
secretly had like a piece of the
whatever they were I don't even remember
what they'll calls anymore and pieces of
Eden God yeah I made a video about it
once where I had to try and describe all
of the first civilization stuff I was
really into that stuff and during like
the Assassin's Creed 2 era it was so
dumb but I loved it it was so funny but
then it got to Revelations I was like
okay we've gone too far yeah
anyway Lucy do you want to do the next
one yeah this is from Robert Jay hello
after dark crew kudos to everyone that's
still working hard during this time what
have you all been doing to stay sane
while being stuck inside during this
pandemic thanks for reading I hope
you'll stay safe and healthy and seem to
you I have mentioned it a little bit
earlier but I've sort of changed my
routine I work I like I change my hours
so I'm nine to five and then at 5:00 I
just shut off I have in my calendar like
this is the time that you exercise and
then I have like cook more I live near
Park so I can go for a walk to get out I
don't know I'm trying not to be I don't
know like I do try and get changed
everyday I don't work from beds I'm
actually reading books that I wanted to
because I have so much more free time
I'm watching Castlevania I'm doing West
Worlds like there's still plenty of
stuff it's just the
hardest balance for me is like we all
use our phones so much and sometimes
that's a good thing to get informed but
at the same time it can just be
relentlessly crushing to your anxiety
because there's so much misinformation
too so I I'm using Twitter a whole lot
less I'm using social media in general a
whole lot less and like I have push
notifications from the BBC because I
feel like that's the stuff I need to
know about rather than I don't need to
read every article about what's going on
because it's just regurgitating a lot of
the same stuff but if it's a push
notification that means something's
change I should know about it but yeah
that's kind of it I'm just trying not to
I'm trying to talk to people more like
reach out it's kind of it it's weird
yeah I mean I would say a big thing for
me is just getting up exercising and
like not staying in bed making sure to
get dressed make my bed like not like
try not to get into the mindset of like
oh I'm just gonna work in my pajamas and
then I'm like eat breakfast at like
11:00 I'm trying to stay on top of that
sort of thing I think this weekend I'll
try to go for a hike or something like
that because I can't imagine there'd be
a lot of people around yeah this weekend
is the one that's gonna be weird for me
like I already cuz I have so many
meetings anyway is that I've booked out
12:30 till 1:30 is my lunch hour and
I've had it in my calendar like that for
a couple months now it's been great and
actually that's been helpful as like
keeping normality there doing some cool
things at work I don't know if you guys
saw your email but while we were
recording like they're setting up little
just informal zoom hangouts that we can
chat to people in the office twice a day
to make sure that people are still like
talking because it's an idea actually
yeah the UK boys have been doing it all
week it's really cool like because I'm
still on the UK calendar I can see them
twice a day like they have little they
have they've been playing smash together
at lunch times because some way they
play smash at lunch and like they have
tea breaks and so they've put that in
account and they'll make a cup of tea
and just sit on a Google hangout and
it's it's super cute
but yeah the discord I added like a
virtual office voice Channel I did one
of the one that was like that would be
something similar because I've seen that
in a couple of the discs I was gonna
explain it but then I got distracted and
didn't but without my idea because I'm
in a couple other discord channels that
have that and it was just not it's not
called virtual office but it's something
similar but like people can just if
they're online hop in and just like chat
with people that would be handy I had
that idea but I wanted to take it a step
further where you create individual
channels in each channel would represent
your your desk so you when you're in
that channel you're sitting at your desk
and you're like oh I'm gonna go see what
Jake's up to so I maybe go over to your
desk
and then or like because in the office
we'll have things happen like Oh
everyone's gonna go around Rob's desk
cuz we're all watching a really funny
video so you'd be like oh hey everyone's
like hanging out at Rob's desk in the
discord what's going on and you go there
and Rob's a screen sharing like a
YouTube video yeah I would say and I'm
not doing a great job keeping myself
sane so far but I'm spending a lot of
time with my dog my dog is undergoing
she's on like a medication course right
now and basically at the end of it she
either gets put down or she doesn't so
it's good that I'm home with her yeah
and I'm worried about my grandma because
she lives by herself
and yeah I'm like not in alright I feel
that like my big thing is that I it's
it's weird moving countries right
because I've always had this kind of
like pocket of money where it's like if
I needed to go home this is my flight
money this is my emergency money and now
I'm at the stage worth like if my mum
gets sick or if my dad and my stepmom
it's like I'm stuck here and my mum
today God love her she was like
but I'm gonna go to Pilates and stuff
and I'm like no you're [ __ ] not gonna
go to Pilates what are you talking about
and then she like messages me back like
an hour late or just like oh just got an
email Pilates has been cancelled I was
like yeah no [ __ ]
insides weird but like you can't let
yourself think like that everyone's in
the same uncertain boat and I'm lucky
that like I have friends back home where
I told them I was worried about this and
they immediately just went look if
anything happens your mom will be there
so it's just it's just distance and I
think the whole thing about this is that
everyone is in the weird boat of like
everything's just so uncertain and so
like I don't know about you guys but
I've been listening to a lot of podcasts
like that I normally listen to but now
and like watching youtubers and stuff
that I usually watch but now I was like
a different meaning because I'm more
grateful for that stuff because it is
just like taking my mind off things and
so that's been quite nice like it's
weird the whole thing is weird no my
yeah my grandpa had pneumonia a couple
months ago so we're like uh yeah are
your lungs recovered
please say yes so it's just like it's
it's like I should have been more
worried about him having pneumonia but I
wasn't at the time it's just like weird
perspective [ __ ] mmm I think as it came
on so quickly - yeah with everything
yeah yeah yeah anyway sorry we got sad
there it was my fault we had no it's not
your fault we haven't done that in a
while what was the episode that we did
and we all just got like super sad at
the end it was like well okay we'll see
you next week we were talking about we
were talking about being cry yes
yeah and then one of the last week was
sad because Peter yeah today's reporting
series last day oh geez oh my god
but anyway I have been walking the dog
to get outside so that's good I like it
when we're on meetings on a call and you
can just hear your dog going mad oh my
god the dogs so like my dog whose name
is Lucy which confute is so confusing I
like her I can tell the difference like
nine times out of ten but sometimes you
say something I'm like hey you know I
told I told Jake like I texted him like
a week ago where I was like Lucy might
need surgery and he thought I was
talking about you were sick you were
sick you were out and I was like oh no
what's going on I've been like I think
you were on a podcast or something like
that or yeah you're on the podcast like
three hours later you're like oh my dog
and I was like okay that's still bad but
I was very concerned for Lucy there's
like a she's 12 and then there's a much
younger one a three year old dog and she
he it was a rescue and he's he just
loses his mind anytime like the garbage
truck drives by and she's just like
super barking yeah we're barking his
barking time so I've been apologizing
for them for the last couple days it's
so cute I mean today Portillo pooped on
Greg while he was streaming I mean dogs
it looks great
that was magical like I didn't even
realize that happened and I was in the
next bloody room as long as he's not
pooping in here that's he's been known
anyway hmm should we wrap this thing
mm-hmm
Oh John Luke did actually did you talk
about what you've been doing
oh geez nothing I feel like most of my
time has been like setting up my like
making sure I can like do [ __ ] from home
then me and Georgia my girlfriend just
trying to find things to do we do not
have a pet unfortunately and we've been
like wanting to get one and then we're
like ah we don't have the time to get
one or we done up the money and now
we're sitting here being like we should
have got a pet
we need a furry creature with us to
comfort and love but yeah i don't know
i'm i started doing ring fit again yeah
cuz i was like into time to get that
exercise going let's do it
I already don't exercise enough as it is
and now I'm definitely not going to be
so doing that more haven't gone outside
since Thursday
I should probably take a walk wait since
last Thursday I think so what no no no I
went in no on didn't you go in the
office I did going to the office today
or two days ago on Monday so no I did go
to the office on Monday okay I did do
that well you're allowed you're allowed
to I mean San Francisco's in a weird
lockdown we're allowed to go for walks
as long as it's with people that you
live with yeah um and that you stay six
feet away from other people it's a bad
combo because we already are home bodies
so it's just it feels like it's an
excuse to just stay inside and we're
like it's not great like I definitely
should probably walk outside otherwise
I'm doing okay yeah well anyway that was
episode 33 of GameSpot after dark thank
you so much for sticking with us for
these next couple weeks yeah we're gonna
keep going until they tell us to stop
that's criminal
yeah you never know but make sure to
email us questions if you've got them
and after dark podcast at gamespot.com
John Luke where can people find you on
Twitter for all your hot doom takes and
impressions you can find me at John Luke
psyche and Lucy I'm at least see James
Games hashtag released the butthole cut
we've titled this episode thank you and
cally uh Ankita gqo do it do the song
and kygo ji cake you see the lines
really good really good that was really
I mean yeah it says a lot about me that
one of the only impressions I can do is
Milhouse Vaughn how brillo oh hell yeah
that might be my island name thank you
I'm gonna be Joe that's good real Howe
Island I'm actually like literally right
after this I'm doing talking Simpsons so
anyway oh wait goodies it for this week
no no no I was gonna see already Johnny
please ignore me
another day I'm so sorry well we'll see
y'all
[Music]